vous êtes vous déjà coucher le premier
soir comme djinékou c'est le seul mec
qui mue à 48 ans j'ai rencontré une
fille je ne sais plus de quel âge
exactement qui avait pris un ecstasy la
drogue c'est de la merde et surtout ça
vraiment je suis lorsqu'il est dit cool
cool relax on peut en venir à une
histoire plus bas on va refaire la même
histoire j'étais avec une vue qu'à mon
cap qui est en train de boire allongée
un red bull rouge pas un docteur cameron
camomille alors oui et moi j'étais là
lui dire relax cool chéri mois six
essais plutôt tranquille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il commence à être déshabillé le premier
soir il a terminé deuxième ce soir
câble a alors que marc vous êtes bloqué
le mans pendant de vercingétorix mais
vous appelez un cadeau qui vous a fait
pour faire paris savent pas si tout est
ce que vous me dites oui mais
vercingétorix elle devrait être contente
parce qu'il tient avec versace tourist
on est sûr d'avoir la gaule pardon c'est
bon je pense tu as fait à cette bagarre
avec je t'aime j'ai là charles de
gaulle-etoile denfert rochereau porter
tous les
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]